(applause)
- Welcome back to TCSN.
We have a really special offer for you.
It's a turkey cheddar sandwich.
- Wow, look at that.
- This is handmade with
avocado, tomato and lettuce
on an artisanal whole wheat baguette
and it can be yours for only
four easy installments of 2.99.
- That is a great deal.
Now I don't know about you,
but I like my sandwiches
with chips and a drink.
- We've got you covered.
Look at this.
A bag of salt and vinegar potato chips
for three payments of 89 cents
and a diet Dr. Dinky cola for
only six payments of 49 cents.
- Whoa, I'm sold and hungry.
How do I sign up?
- Just send us your name, phone number,
date of birth and social security number
and you can get approved in seconds.
- So easy.
- Paying for a sandwich in installments
may seem absurd to some,
but the practice is becoming
more and more popular
especially among younger shoppers.
- Buy now, pay later loans
are one of the hottest new trends
in the world of financial technology,
touted as a less risky
alternative to credit cards.
Using one of several major apps
you're only asked for a fraction
of the price at the point of sale
and the rest is paid off
in a few biweekly installments.
As long as you pay on time,
there's no interest.
- No interest?
- Oh, hold on Turbo,
it might sound like a no-brainer,
but any savvy spender knows
you don't dive headfirst
into a new financial tool
without digging a little deeper.
How do BNPL loans really work?
What are the drawbacks and dangers
and what's in it for the
companies that offer them?
(upbeat music)
- Times were tough during
the Great Depression
and people weren't
spending like they used to.
So merchants came up with a new system
called a layaway plan
which allowed shoppers to put
a deposit down on a purchase
and pay the rest off in installments.
When the balance is fully paid off,
the merchandise is delivered.
- Layaway plans were
popular up until the 1980s
when credit cards replaced them
as the preferred way to buy things
with money you don't have.
But over the last four decades
many Americans have
soured on credit cards,
associating them with
high interest payments
and lifelong debt spirals.
- So it's no wonder that young people
are starting to embrace
Buy Now Pay Later loans
as a kind of modern tech
reboot of the layaway plan.
Like layaway plans,
they have a no interest
installment structure,
but like credit cards,
you receive the purchase immediately.
You don't have to wait until
the balance is paid off.
- If you think this
sounds like a good deal,
you're not alone.
Between 2019 and 2021,
the total value of BNPL
loans from the major lenders
grew more than a thousand percent
from around 2 billion to over 24 billion.
The value of transactions
financed this way
quadrupled globally,
hitting over 120 billion.
More than 40% of Americans
have used BNPL loans
and they're especially
popular with younger people,
who make up about half the user base.
- And they seem to like it.
According to consumer reports,
most users report being
satisfied with the service
and a survey by associate
marketing Professor Anastasia Ghosh
found that unlike credit cards,
consumers felt virtually no guilt
about using BNPL loans.
- This is the part where
we say, however, isn't it?
- Yes, it is.
However, there are drawbacks to BNPL loans
that consumer rights advocates
are trying to sound the alarm on.
These are extremely new
financial inventions,
which means they're largely unregulated.
The Truth in Lending Act,
which protects you from unfair
or inaccurate credit practices,
doesn't apply to Buy Now, Pay Later.
They don't have the rewards programs
or protections of credit cards,
which means you might not
be able to get a refund
if your purchase is lost
or damaged in transit.
- And just because there's no interest
doesn't mean there aren't
penalties for late payments.
Delinquency rates for BNPL
loans have been steadily growing
over the last few years,
as have loans charged off as bad debt.
When this happens,
your credit rating takes a hit,
but the reverse is not true.
Most BNPL companies don't
report on-time payments
to the credit bureaus,
which means they're not a viable way
to build your credit history.
- Also, one of BNPL'S
most attractive features,
its ease of use,
is also a hazard.
People are increasingly using
them for everyday purchases
like groceries, utility
bills, and yes sandwiches.
This can lead to loan stacking
where borrowers quickly lose
track of multiple loans.
People who use BNPL loans
have seen a dramatic uptick
in overdraft fees and
because many have their
BNPL accounts tied to their credit cards,
they end up paying interest anyway.
- But to understand the
true danger of BNPL loans,
we need to look at the business strategy
of the companies that offer them.
These apps market themselves
as friendly, cool,
almost altruistic organizations
just trying to help you
live your best life, bro,
but we savvy shoppers
know that no corporation
does anything unless there's
something in it for them.
Which begs the question,
how does a lender that doesn't
charge interest make money?
- The answer is merchant fees.
Retailers pay BNPL companies to finance
their customers loans
and the fees are three
to four times higher
than those from credit card companies.
Which begs another question,
why are merchants willing to
pay such exorbitant prices?
Because BNPL companies
are really, really good
at getting customers to spend more money.
- If you're surfing an
online clothing store
with a hundred bucks to spend,
you might see a cute top that
usually goes for 80 bucks,
but you can have it right now
for a deposit of just $20.
Throw in a shawl, a hat, pair of boots
and your $100 has financed
a whole new outfit...
with about $300 in
installments to pay off.
- A recent economic study
found that using BNPL loans
increases one's spending
habit by $60 a week,
bloating the average American's
retail budget by about 30%.
Meanwhile, they're tracking your purchases
and collecting your data to develop more
effective ways to get you to spend more.
As the director of the
Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau put it,
these firms aren't just lenders,
they're also advertisers
and virtual mall operators.
- We have a tendency to
become entranced by new tech
and think that apps with
upbeat names and hip marketing
are really changing the
game for the better,
but as we've seen before,
some tech companies are not so
much disrupting the industry
as just muscling their way into it.
- That's why some
economists think that this
Buy Now, Pay Later fad
is just another loop
in America's eternal credit cycle.
It may seem like the shiny new thing,
but it will quickly lose its luster
if consumers keep overspending
themselves into debt.
- [Group] And that's our 2 cents.
- Thanks to our patrons
for keeping 2 cents
financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a 2 cents patron.
Wanna know more about how the internet
nudges you to overspend?
Check out our video, How
Social Media Keeps You Poor.
(upbeat music)